[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity more bad news for Hillary
Clinton this week involving another one
of her scandals the chairman of the
House Judiciary and oversight committees
have announced that they're opening a
new probe into how the FBI and DOJ
handled the investigation into Clinton's
private server also this week Judicial
Watch announced that last year the FBI
recovered 72 thousand pages of Clinton
email records 40,000 of which the State
Department still has to process joining
us now is the president of Judicial
Watch tom Fitton and from the american
center for law and justice
jordan Sekulow all right tom let me ask
you what is the the latest in terms of
the information that you've gotten from
your subpoenas well he's a Freedom of
Information Act request we've been
asking for these emails for years and
they've been stonewalling the release of
the information even under this new
administration the Deep States running
things at the State Department Justice
Department on these Clinton emails and
as you highlighted they're 72,000 pages
of Clinton emails the FBI went and found
and these are the emails Hillary Clinton
tried the delete that the FBI found or
recovered and they've only released a
few of them and at the rate they're
releasing him to us now we won't get all
of them until 2020 and on top of that
there are 28 hundred pages of records or
documents over an Anthony Weiner's
laptop that Yuma Abedini had that we're
also government records that are also
from the Clinton email server we don't
know what's in them it's a classified
information is it Russian information
what was being what was being deleted by
Hillary Clinton is the big mystery well
you know my take if we've got 70 to a
thousand emails and the State Department
that was asked for them by at the time
of Benghazi how many years ago was that
in 2012 and it's taken him this long I
have an idea let's defund Muller and his
special counsel and use that money to
get people to start releasing the
State Department emails and and and you
know Jordan what what say you about this
well I think that I am encouraged that
Congress is now looking at this judge
for input with a new lens and a couple
different ways one when it comes to the
new investigations under how the FBI
handled the the this whole really
investigation they never wanted to call
it that matter I guess in to Hillary
Clinton why they were so public and kept
telling Congress and giving them updates
about Hillary Clinton and then made the
ultimate call not to prosecute instead
of deferring to the Department of
Justice the normal course of action and
then also you know trey Gowdy who chairs
Oversight Committee wants to bring Jim
Comey back to testify under oath that's
important but second and I think this
ties to a FOIA that we're working on
right now at ACL J is that the FBI we
now know was part of had inked a deal it
appears with Christopher Steele to
continue the opposition research that
Hillary Clinton's campaign was paying
for fusion GPS we want to know how far
along the FBI went so we've we foiled
filed when the foyer with the FBI to get
that information judge because that is
absurd as you said earlier in the
broadcast it taints everything if the
starting point for the unmasking if the
starting point for the special counsel
if the starting point for all of all of
this
Trump Russia info is really a Hillary
Clinton Russian scandal well clearly
clearly I mean it you know of people
have used this term alway in the for the
last few days the whole thing is turned
on its head but Tom $50,000.00 I believe
is gone from the FBI to christopher
Steele how do they justify that and is
that the correct amount well we don't
know and and we've asked for the
documents to in fact we're already in
federal court on it and the Justice
Department FBI have told us they can't
confirm or deny whether any documents
exist for about the dossier or payments
related to it so this is where we stand
everyone just talking about the FBI's
relationship with Christopher Steele but
the FBI doesn't want to say anything
about it and now they're going to turn
over some documents to Congress we
wonder if they're going to update the
court as to whether they still believe
they can credibly say they can't confirm
or deny whether documents exist lack of
transparency is convenient it's helping
Hillary Clinton Barack Obama and hurting
president Trump well clearly and it's
also hurting the credibility of law
enforcement you know judge I mean that
is ultimately what is so damaging here
is that people's faith in our top law
enforcement agencies like the FBI
it's totally undercut when they behave
this way well clearly as between Comey
and Muller they have done more to
destroy the country's confidence in the
FBI as someone who works in law
enforcement for over three decades what
they have done is stunning if this Trump
dossier is the basis of FISA warrants
and the unmasking of Americans and was
used but knowingly funded by the Clinton
campaign and Jim Comey is the guy who
goes out when it's not his job Tom and
makes a decision that he's going to
exonerate Hillary I mean then the whole
criminal justice system falls on its
head you know the Clinton Clinton
campaign and the DNC have their problems
with the dossier but to the extent the
FBI and Justice Department used this
dossier as a pretext to spy on president
Trump's team where President Trump
himself this is much more significant
government scandal in terms of the Obama
administration the Justice Department
and the FBI then frankly anything
Hillary Clinton did well clearly and and
Jordan final question I mean what what
can we look forward to in the next few
weeks I think that that confidential
informant is going to change everything
I think it's why you're gonna start
seeing both sides try to speed up their
activity because you've got people on
the run right now so to speak in
Washington DC and now they know a
confidential informant is going to be
able to provide information on the
influence Russians we're trying to
assert on the Clintons both Hillary and
Bill Clinton specific to uranium deals
in the United States that were
ultimately approved by President Obama
very sad all right tom Fitton Jordan
Sekulow thanks so much for being with us
you're welcome